the president is spending the weekend at
his delaware home his first trip away
from the white house since his
inauguration
mr biden left washington no closer to a
bipartisan deal in his economic relief
package but well aware of the steep
climb ahead
this after the labor department reported
friday that only 49
000 new jobs were created last month
christina rafini
is traveling with the president in
wilmington delaware this morning
what do you have for us christina good
morning back in his senate days then mr
biden was famous for riding the amtrak
back and forth to washington now that
he's president however
he's gotten a bit of an upgrade
this short approximately half hour
flight was the first time president
biden has been on air force one
since taking office i'm getting off that
plane
a surreal moment after a week of hard
reality
trying to get republicans to get on
board with his coveted relief plan
they're americans and they're suffering
after another round of disappointing
jobs numbers
just 49 000 of them created last month
the president rebuked republicans who
have called the plan
too expensive so i'm going to act i'm
going to act
fast i'd like to be
i'd like to be doing it with the support
of republicans but they're just not
willing to go as far as i think we have
to go
the nearly 2 trillion package includes a
hundred and sixty billion dollars
to expand covet vaccine testing and
vaccination programs
it increases and extends unemployment
benefits through september
and provides lower and moderate income
americans fourteen hundred dollar checks
but big is too big for many republicans
the only
organizing principle in this bill that i
can figure out is
the desire to spend a massive amount of
money
they want a deal about one-third the
size of what the president is proposing
including smaller more targeted relief
payments the remaining damage to our
economy does not require another
multi-trillion dollar non-targeted
band-aid
vice president votes in the affirmative
yesterday vice president
kamala harris cast the tie-breaking vote
in the senate
on a budget measure that paves the way
for democrats to pass the coveted relief
plan
without republican support and at the
white house mr biden met with democratic
leaders for a strategy session
we would hope we can proceed in a
bipartisan way
and that was part of the thrust of our
meeting with the president
rest and relaxation aren't the only
thing on the agenda mr biden said he
also had to come back home to get the
rest of his stuff
due to the rocky transition period the
bidens never had a chance to move all
their things
into the white house jeff okay christina
thank you very much